best friends janine bob and moyer and
sarah harker are in their hometown of
indianapolis these moms are dedicated to
connecting moms across the city and now
we're about to connect with them and
their love of indy watch this
hi drew i'm janine i'm sarah we are so
excited to take you around indianapolis
today to some of our favorite places
drew you're going to love it i cannot
wait did you just say drew as a drew
barrymore uh yeah
wow hello hey guys hey drew it's ryan
and jillian from indie now on fox 59.
yeah we were just going into work what
are you guys doing here we are going to
do a road trip for drew and take her to
some of our favorite spots around india
today awesome awesome yeah yeah we're on
a tight schedule all right
okay
okay all right drew let's go
we're at holiday park it's one of the
gems of the indianapolis park system i
love the programming at holiday park
including yoga at the ruins which is
where we are today it's a little rainy
out thanks a lot indianapolis weather
but i think we'll still get a good class
in keep your right arm up take a big
stretch
welcome to the garage in downtown
indianapolis we are so excited to show
you around today drew you're going to
love the garage it's one of our favorite
places to grab something to eat there's
a ton of different vendors that you can
choose from and it was just recently
voted one of time magazine's number one
places to visit in the country don't
forget we've got one more place that we
need to take you any ideas
give me a hint okay ready okay
let's go to the speedway
you're gonna love the indianapolis motor
speedway this is one of the biggest and
best attractions in the entire city it
is where racing happens all year round
indianapolis is the racing capital of
the world
drew we got your flag ready for you on
your camaro you're so ready
thanks so much for hanging out with us
today drew we've had a blast we have
loved showing you around indianapolis
and i think we need to take one last lap
here we go
[Music]
you